llegó el momento de la información
económica en france 24 por eso saludo a
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
vamos a empezar hablando de afganistán
el tema del momento porque hay una
escasez de alimentos en este país así de
según funcionarios del programa mundial
de alimentos declararon que las reservas
de alimentos en ese país podrán agotarse
este mes esto sumaría una crisis
alimentaria a la crisis política y
económica que vive afganistán desde hace
15 días con la toma del poder del grupo
talibán el organismo advierte que con el
invierno acercándose y la sequía en
curso se necesitarán de forma urgente
juan al menos 200 millones de dólares de
forma urgente aunque se requieren a
nivel macro unos 1.300 millones de
dólares para atender la emergencia de
los cuales sólo han recibido el 39 por
ciento el programa de la onu aseguró que
en ese país de 38 millones de habitantes
al menos un tercio de la población no
tiene certezas y comerá todos los días
los mercados de afganistán comienzan a
reportar aumentos de precios en los
productos básicos de entre 10 a 20 por
ciento efecto de la inestabilidad
política que se vive pasamos a hablar de
la región de américa latina
concretamente de la
de nicaragua así es el gobierno de
nicaragua anunció que va a exonerar el
impuesto al valor agregado al sector
turismo en el segundo año consecutivo
que nicaragua toma esta medida para
fiestas patrias con el fin de incentivar
el turismo y el consumo local la
exoneración del iva será válida del 14
al 17 de septiembre para
establecimientos de consumo como bares
hoteles y restaurantes está medida esta
compañía de 10 días de vacaciones con
goce de salario a los trabajadores
estatales en ocasión el 200 aniversario
de la independencia de españa
el anuncio juan causó cierta
controversia debido a que médicos
independientes alertan que en el país
existe un repunte de casos de kobe 19 en
los hospitales pero el gobierno insiste
en tener la situación bajo control y
promueve active actividades culturales y
de entretenimiento vamos a hablar ahora
de uno de los gigantes económicos del
mundo de las ventas en línea amazon que
está buscando trabajadores así es el
gigante de internet anunció que planea
contratar a 55 mil nuevos empleados en
todo el mundo próximamente de ese total
al menos 40 mil serán en eeuu amazon
declaró que la vacantes son para puestos
tecnológicos y corporativos la demanda
de esta empresa crece a medida que las
personas se quedan en casa
imagínate que tan solo durante la
pandemia de kobe 19 la empresa contrató
casi a 500 mil personas este es un
promedio de 1400 personas contratadas
por días en los primeros 10 meses del
año pasado mientras muchas empresas
estaban despidiendo personal entonces
actualmente la empresa emplea a 1,3
millones de trabajadores en todo el
mundo aunque enfrenta críticas sobre el
trato a sus colaboradores la nueva
demanda de contrataciones se debe a la
expansión de negocios y en particular a
un proyecto de enviar satélites al
espacio para brindar internet a la
tierra una de las empresas que más se ha
beneficiado de la pandemia sin duda
alguna pasamos a hablar de eeuu porque
le quiere apostar al comercio del litio
así es con la creciente demanda de
vehículos eléctricos se acelera la
inversión para extraer litio del agua
subterránea y el foco está ahora en este
cuerpo de agua el saltón si es el lago
más grande de california
general motors y otras empresas buscan
convertirse o convertir este agonizante
lago fuentes de este metal este lago se
formó en 1905 y es alimentado por el río
colorado en algún momento fue un popular
destino turístico pero se deterioró por
varias inundaciones y posteriormente se
secó por falta de lluvias el proyecto de
extracción de litio pretende convertir a
eeuu en competencia de países como
australia chile argentina
y china empresas como energy search
anunciaron inversiones por 500 millones
de dólares para comenzar a operar en el
año 2024
'jorge indicadores económicos bueno
arrancamos con wall street que cerró
mixto a la espera de las cifras de
empleo de agosto que se darán a conocer
este viernes en américa latina' la bolsa
argentina cayó levemente afectado por la
baja en el índice de riesgo-país y para
terminar la cifra del día bueno esta
cifra no es muy alentadora a 500.000
millones de dólares podrían subir los
costos económicos causados en la salud
pública de eeuu para el año 2050 todo
esto producto del cambio climático y
específicamente de los calores extremos
comenzar a nadar según la firma en
atlantic council no es nada alentadora
cifra jorge muchísimas gracias y gracias
también ustedes quédense en la pantalla
de france 24
[Música]
i